truck men in Dudley has been making
parts for four-by-fours for 35 years it
employs nearly 90 people in the UK and
works with some of the world's biggest
car makers it's exactly the sort of
British manufacturing business that will
have been listening closely to Boris
Johnson's speech this week setting out
his vision for a future trading
relationship with the EU and looking for
reassurance Mike wheeler founded the
firm from his shed and is ambitious
about its future ok these these are all
doors so these will end up actually on
the hard tops which we'll see in a
minute in assembly so to come out of the
mould and these are sort of finishes
we're achieving from the mould so really
really high gloss very shiny yep and the
next part of the process is to trim it
and then once they're trimmed we just do
final finishing yeah to make the product
smooth make sure of any no defects
yeah we start off with buckets the resin
rolls have met and we end up with this
product all on one site it's mainly the
UK market that you service or do you
deal a lot with the EU market as well
our market historically has been the UK
the UK is the biggest pick up market in
Europe we've got the the business to a
size we're getting the growth of 15 20
percent out of the UK market was no
longer possible
so we've then looked to export so we're
doing about 10% of our sales in two
countries and it's the EU that you feel
is like a natural market to expand into
them yes it is you know for many reasons
obviously proximity makes a big
difference in terms of our sales effort
and supporting and delivery but
culturally you know they're very similar
in terms of the way they use the product
and also the way that they're very open
to working in partnership I mean some
would say that you know post brexit the
whole of the world is a possible market
for British businesses we should be
looking more to trade with the u.s. or
China or Australia I mean is that
realistic do you think the businesses
like yours no not not from our UK
manufacturing site and also those
markets have very different tastes and
needs so the American market is a huge
pickup market but actually all their
vehicles are different to ours and then
when we look at sort of markets like
India there isn't a big pickup market
which uses part ops so yes there are
other markets but they're so far away
they would be difficult for us to
service economically Boris Johnson has
been talking a lot about divergence as
well effectively saying he doesn't want
to just have to follow rules and
standards what do you make of that from
a business perspective we're starting
off from a level playing field so you
know all of our legislation is is is the
same so in terms of the quality the
standards for our products
you know we cannot have two standards in
our production and we can't have two
standards in our stock that wouldn't be
efficient so if you like a higher
standard for the e market and a lower
standard for the rest of the work
correct so you know we manufacture to
our own standards which comply with
those regulatory requirements for the
markets that we're in so we'll only make
what to one standard so even if we ended
up with lower standards in the UK we
would still make to the same standards
or even the other way around
you know if the higher standards were in
the UK we'd make to those so you a bit
worried about this talk--i divergences I
don't think it's realistic in it from a
manufacturing standpoint at a trading
standpoint you know we've got 3.8
million pounds worth of stock I'm not
going to carry to lots of stock because
I won't get the efficiency so it's of no
benefit for us both for us Johnson and
the EU have been talking tough ahead of
the next phase of talks right now it's
difficult to separate the sabre-rattling
from the genuine negotiating positions
for business is paying close attention
to the government's talk of divergence I
think the first thing is actually it's
been it's been quite a good start to the
year for business I mean optimism has
improved all our surveys show that and
the challenge now the opportunity is to
turn that optimism into investment joke
growth jobs that's what we've got to do
and the brexit conversation sort of
exists within that framework so
businesses are of course really
interested in what's going to happen
they do see a government with a strong
mandate likely to actually follow quite
a clear path but they want to get
involved they want to be offering advice
and help because every decision we take
it's going to affect business so they've
got the insight to show how it will work
on the ground well there are lots of
decisions that I mean at the at the
moment that could could be helpful or
could be damaging if you take divergence
as an example there are what about
19,000 other statutes that we need to do
we need to look at some of them could
reduce red tape in agriculture or
recycling targets some of them though if
we get them wrong just double the
bureaucracy that businesses face so
there is opportunity but there is also
risk and again the only way that we'll
get that right is if government business
work together to go through the details
step by step and make the right
decisions
companies like Trotman are confident
that whatever happens with brexit they
will have a successful future but to
unleash their full potential they're
relying on the prime minister to deliver
in the next set of negotiations